Hm.
What's up guys, Michael here to use my philosophy degree to examine a,
another piece of the pop culture Canon this time, we're going back to college,
a place known for intellectual exploration, social development,
and signed atheism pledge is due on the first day of class.
If that last one didn't bring back any memories,
then you didn't attend a Hadley university,
a fictional college where philosophy is taught by a washed up Hercules who was
like really, really mad at God. Like.
Yes, I hate.
God. This is the setting of God's not dead.
The first installment in a trilogy produced by the company,
pure flicks like Netflix, but pure.
It presents a vision of America in which angry philosophers are on a mission to
destroy Christianity as both a former non angry philosophy professor and guy who
went to Christian summer camp.
Once you might understand why this film is of particular interest to me.
So let's see how this film portrays the brave and potentially nefarious souls
who have gone into life destroying debt to teach philosophy.
And this philosophy reacts to God's not dead before we get into the
philosophical nuance of a film that lets you know what character is a radical
atheist by the I love evolution sticker on the back of her car.
I wanted to take a second to tell you about wisecracks podcast because you're
here right now, looking deeply into my eyes.
I can safely assume you're already a fan of our video content,
but what you might not know is that we also make pretty good audio content and
my totally unbiased opinion. If you love movies, which I mean, why wouldn't you,
you should check out. Show me the meaning where our hosts, Austin,
Raymond and Ryan explore all the philosophical nuance floating beneath the
surface of both current and classic films.
And if you're potentially too obsessed with everything going on in pop culture,
you should check out culture binge the podcast where we explore the weird,
wonderful and worrisome sides of the cultural zeitgeist.
It's hosted by someone you already know in love more of a brother than a friend,
along with wisecracks, head of content, Alec and wisecrack researcher survey.
So click the links in the description or find them on your favorite podcast app.
Now back to the show and now for a quick recap, Josh Weeden,
no relation to Josh.
Sweden is a freshmen student who shows up to his philosophy one 50 class.
Whereas professor explains that before they begin,
everyone must sign a paper that says, God is dead.
Josh can't do this because he's a Christian. I can't do what you want.
I'm a Christian.
So the professor insists that unless he wants to lose 30% of his grade,
he must convince the entire class that God's not dead.
You'll get three sessions.
The last 20 minutes of each of the next three classes to make
your case.
Please do a series of awkwardly,
incense showdowns between Josh and his professor,
which ends with Josh rocking out at a concert and the professor. Well,
I'm not rocking out at all, but more on that later.
And while I would love to also explore the films and numerous absurd and often
dark plot lines,
including a breathtaking performance from Willie Robertson of duck dynasty fame.
So y'all had made a fortune. Isn't that right? We're doing all right.
And certainly by a bigger tires on our trucks and four wheelers to get out in
the mud with. So life is good.
We're going to stick to the philosophy stuff. Okay?
Check out the first day of class.
Michelle for cool. They're trying to wrestle Ludwig, Feuerbach,
patrolled Brecht. What do they all have
in common? They're all dead.
That would be incorrect. Mr. Dawkins,
Mr. Chomsky is still very much alive. Mr. G dog to rock trigger.
He said his name was G dog G dog. Well,
they are or were
atheists. Okay.
Um, the G dog thing has me shook with some of these names.
Fuko Nicha,
humil Russell might very well be on an intro to philosophy syllabus,
but others he has on here.
Dawkins Chomsky Brecht would be very unlikely inclusions as there. Um,
not philosophers also. There's no way that that's his handwriting at all,
but nitpicky basic fact-checking aside. There's a way bigger problem.
Defining these philosophers as fundamentally atheist, for example,
um, David Hume's philosophy, isn't categorically atheist.
He simply thinks that human knowledge has a pretty limited scope and that even
if a thing like God exists, we don't have the intellectual ability to prove it.
This is if you shared by many non atheist,
including some priest and theologians,
I've had beers with over the years and Feuerbach,
wasn't so much about militant atheism.
He just thought that theology is actually about anthropology.
Which just means that sometimes when we talk about how amazing God is,
we're just reflecting on some of the best aspects of our own humanity. Okay,
let's see what he said.
Next this semester,
I propose that we refuse to waste our limited time
together, debating the existence of the big man in the sky, the myth.
This would never, ever happen.
You just can't have a historical introduction to philosophy that skips over the
discussion of God. Now,
I don't know what's on every philosophy syllabus in the world,
but your typical intro to philosophy course,
it definitely has some medieval philosophy,
which is almost exclusively Christian and Muslim people like Thomas Aquinas, St.
Gustin or at the center.
And even in an intro to philosophy course had some anti-God biases.
It would still be weird to skip past philosophical heavyweights like George
Hagle or Soren Kierkegaard, along with hipper thinkers like Emmanuel Levinas,
Jacques Derrida, and even sloppy Slovenian Santa Claus.
Slavo jijak all of whom have seriously engaged with religion and theology in
their work.
All of which is to say this imaginary philosophy class would be seriously
incomplete. Okay. Let's see what this hero does now.
God is dead. Oh, is he?
This is of course a metaphor, but an illustrated one.
Meaning not that God somehow died,
but rather that he never existed in the first place.
All that it required from each of you is that you fill in the papers.
I've just given you a three little words.
God is dead.
God, I would, I would pay money to see this guys rate my professor page.
Although I think he would get a chili pepper because skill looking guy, okay,
this is, this is just, this is ridiculous. Um,
it would never happen ever under any circumstance. Also,
if I'd ever tried to pull something like this,
my brilliant and not idiot students would have told me off categorical
statements like this are antithetical to the entire spirit of philosophy,
which should include space for wonder curiosity,
and be careful examination of a wide range of positions.
Okay. Time to meet our friend, Josh.
Mr. Weakness, something wrong. Yeah, I can't,
I can't do what you want. I'm a Christian. Allow me to explain the alternative.
If you cannot bring yourself to admit that God is dead for the purposes of this
class and you will need to defend the antithesis, that God is not dead.
But this is all types of absurd.
And for a little inside baseball in most academic departments, syllabus,
and course structures are things that are shared with and peer reviewed by your
colleagues. So if I was teaching a course and put publicly declaring,
God is dead equals 30% of overall grade. My colleagues would say, abs,
absolutely not.
And there might be a further meeting to evaluate my overall soundness of mind.
This is also God awful teaching the goal of academic philosophy.
Isn't to instill hardcore ideological concepts into the brains of impressionable
young people.
That's what the entire media and advertising industries before rather it's to
help people learn how to think more critically about themselves in the world,
around them, but professor protein in his toothpaste,
isn't encouraging Josh to get more curious about his beliefs.
He's basically forcing him to take on an equally inflexible position.
Once again,
not the vibes of philosophy you've likely heard of the Socratic method,
which describes how the OGE of the game Socrates pot,
which was basically by walking around and asking questions.
The point wasn't to implant information, but to inspire thoughts.
Okay. Let's move on and see how our guy Josh does at his first guest lecture.
Wait, I want to see one more thing real quick.
For our next class. Please have read David Humes,
the problems of induction when they day carts discourse on method,
which you may add Bertrand. Russell's why I am not a Christian.
Oh, okay. Okay. Um, wait, I need to talk about these assignments.
He didn't even hand out a syllabus or do any actual teaching,
but now he's assigning to difficult texts from modern philosophy.
And one of these by Descartes includes an entire section where he offers three
separate proofs for the existence of God. Well done,
professor too cool for church. Okay. Now we can move on.
Most.
Cosmologists now agree that the universe began some 13.7 billion years
ago in an event known as the big bang,
the entire universe jumping into existence and a trillionth of a trillionth of a
second out of nothingness and an unimaginably intense flash of light
is how he would expect the universe to respond.
If God were to actually utter the command in Genesis one, three,
let there be light.
Okay. Uh, this isn't it Josh. It just, it just isn't.
So here are fledgling philosophers pushing a God of the gaps argument
in which God is being used as filler for explanatory gaps in philosophical or
scientific knowledge.
So we can't understand what was happening before the big bang. No problem.
God did it. It was struggling to understand the foundations of mathematics.
God obviously unsure of why you find yourself sweating profusely while wearing a
t-shirt on a 65 degree day with low humidity guys.
I think God did this to me. Now, if I were Josh,
I would have maybe brought up ontological argument for the existence of God,
which coincidentally was in one of the first readings developed by Anselm and
popularized by Descartes,
which super briefly argues that there must be a beam than which no greater can
be conceived.
This is at least a philosophical argument and not an argument for God's ability
to snap his fingers in a stenosis like fashion to make stuff exist.
Yeah.
But all that said Josh,
his argument that God is the only good explanation for the emergence of matter
in the universe is kind of like saying God is the only explanation for why honey
and hot sauce compliment each other so well. Okay.
Let's see what happens after class.
You think you're smarter than me Wheaton.
Do you think there's any argument you can make that I won't have an answer for?
I never said I was smarter.
That's the first intelligent thing you've said in that classroom.
There is a God and yet I'm him, but know this.
If you truly feel a need to continue with this charade,
I will make it my personal mission to destroy any hope of a lot of grit in your
view.
Ah, okay. It's the safety obvious a professor at an academic institution.
It would never be able to chase a student down the hallway to physically and
verbally assault him without being fired.
Pretty much immediately guys like the OJ Simpson, philosophical educators. Well,
plenty of certifiably, bad things happen from here. Sadly.
None of it really has much to do with philosophy.
So let's skip ahead to Josh's next lecture.
It's like this.
If I say to you that I can prove that spam is the best tasting food that's ever
existed because you get all of history, no food has ever tasted better.
You'd probably look at me strange and say,
I haven't proven anything and you'd be right.
But when hockey claims that the universe created itself because it needed to
create itself and then offers that as an explanation as to how and why it was
created, we don't immediately recognize that he's doing the same thing,
but he is.
Oh, okay. Um, what a logic bro, energy right here.
But keep in mind that Hawking is professor goddess, essence favorite thinker.
And here Josh is trying to slightly use Hawkins theories against him.
Basically my man's pulling a weird appeal to authority card in lieu of making an
actual argument. But again, the problem is that Hawking is,
as previously mentioned a scientist and not a philosopher making philosophical
arguments. Kayla let's watch our guy try to frigging home here.
But, but if you can't bear to disagree with Hawking's thinking,
then I suggest that you turn to page five of his book where he insists
philosophy is dead.
And if you're so sure professor Hawking's infallibility and philosophy really is
dead, then, uh,
there's really no need for this class.
Whew, it's coming in a little hot there.
So with all due respect to Josh who at this point has been dumped by his
girlfriend of six years,
simply because he decided to defend God in philosophy class,
a real thing that happens in the film. Uh, this has nothing to do with anything.
His argument is that in the last lecture professor big balls said that Hawkin
was smart and also said that God isn't real.
And since smart people aren't wrong, God isn't real.
But now the smart man is same philosophy is dead. And if he's really that smart,
wouldn't he be right again? Um,
I just blame Stephen Hawking in his irrational hatred of philosophy for this
one. They hatred,
which makes no sense because philosophy created the very foundations of modern
science. Okay. Uh,
Josh has one chance left to once and for all prove the existence of God and make
atheism in untenable belief for the rest of time. Let's see if he can do it.
And before we get into Josh's third lecture, some crucial context, professor,
big Mac,
no pickles stuck around after class to mock Josh and ended up revealing that he
used to be a Christian until he lost his mom as a 12 year old,
this will come up again. It's only natural to beg God for her life. Okay.
It's Josh's final chance. Let's see if he does it.
It's that story famously pointed out.
If God does not exist,
everything is permissible.
Professor Radison is right then all of this,
whatever we decide here is meaningless.
I mean our lives and ultimately our deaths are no more consequences.
That of a goldfish.
This is ridiculous. Why does he hate goldfish? Like if you have one,
maybe your parents want you to get a dog and you get a goldfish and you name it
freckles. And it's your friend. And Josh was just out here, like flushed them.
But last time Josh made a mistake by tying his argument to a random quote from a
physicist. This time he uses a quote from Russian novelist, uh,
Theodore Dostoevsky, except it really isn't a quote from Dostoyevsky,
but a line of dialogue from his novel, the brothers Karamazov.
It's an interesting line from an interesting novel and lots of philosophers have
interacted with it over the years,
but it's less of a forceful argument than a starting point for an interesting
discussion.
But Josh uses this quote in the context of a larger argument about how without
the existence of God, we have no reason to be moral.
And a lot can be said about this because most ethical moral philosophies don't
have the existence of God as their first principle.
One of my personal favorite arguments for a system of humanist, ethics,
not grounded in theological principles is articulated by noted amphetamine
enthusiast. John Paul Sartre and existentialism is a humanism. And it,
he argues that if there is no God to give us moral principles,
we have to take on that responsibility for ourselves and engage in an ongoing
process of figuring out how to live a good life. You should read it.
It's easy to find as Jay Z once said type it in. Google is your friend, bruh,
even though Josh is a much more sympathetic character than professor steroids
smoothie, and I'm weirdly rooting for him. He's not really saying anything here.
So let's, let's see his final argument.
Yeah. Who you really looking to fail professor
or God God's GPA is.
It's a very simple question, professor. Why did you hate God?
Because he took everything away from me. Yes.
I hate God. How can you hate someone?
They don't exist.
So that's a lot. They really build some tension there. Um,
but now we're diving into the realm of the theological effects
of psychological trauma on a teenager,
both professor big penis and Josh are bad at philosophy,
but at least Josh has an excuse,
which is that rather than teaching them philosophy, his professor has been busy,
physically threatening him still rather than providing any convincing argument.
Josh finishes professor and pushups by pointing out that his intellectual
framework is simply a reaction to his mother's death.
While we have sympathy for Josh here,
bullying your opponent about a traumatic loss.
Isn't the way to win philosophical debate. But Hey,
when I was a college freshmen,
I didn't even know you were supposed to wash your sheets more than once a year.
So who am I to judge? Okay. But if I were to judge,
clearly the filmmakers have no idea what philosophy actually is or what it does
or what a philosophy class is actually like,
nor do they appear to have been anywhere in the vicinity of an open book of
philosophy. Instead,
they just cooked up an entire film based on a misreading of a line from German
philosopher, Friedrich, Nietzsche, the line, God is dead and we have killed him.
This was a way for nature to criticize European culture and philosophy,
not some simplistic reporting of the homicide of a daddy.
He was pointing out how the rationalism of enlightenment philosophy had
explained a way the need for God. But since folks didn't notice this,
they were incapable of thinking about what meaning and morality without God even
looks like of knowing this would have required the filmmakers to read three to
four full sentences. And I'm sure they were real busy doing God's stuff. Well,
there you have it. A two hour film about a philosophy class.
That's almost completely devoid of actual philosophy. It's a low bar,
but you can probably learn more about Nisha by watching Gilmore.
Girls. This girl could name the state capitals at three,
recite the periodic table at four,
discuss Schopenhauer his influence on nature when she was 10.
Oh, and just so we don't leave you hanging at the end of the film.
Professor cold cuts gets hit by a car flies through the air,
hits the deck like a ton of bricks and dies as he's converted to Christianity by
two ministers on their way to Disney.
Are you willing to put your faith in Jesus Christ?
Are you willing to take that chance?
And then while he's lying in the street dead,
the dude from duck dynasty makes fun of him on a jumbotron at a Christian rock
concert, and then the crowd boos him. One of your professors.
Insisted that God is dead.
All while he's lifeless on the street,
a block away with two Grinny ministers standing over him in philosophical terms.
This is what we call what the, so what do you guys think?
Should I be forced to watch the two sequels to try and uncover the brilliant
philosophical core at the heart of this trilogy?
Or should I have taken Christopher's advice and Gilmore girls and joined the
military? Well, if your dreams.
Don't pan out and Nietzsche's no help, it's a viable option.
Let us know in the comments and please leave me suggestions about any other
philosophically minded shows, films or games that I should check out. Huge.
Thanks to our patrons for all your support hit that subscribe button.
Like you're a distracted driver trying to end the life of a washed up
philosopher and ring that bell.
Like it's the end of an intellectually stimulating semester.
It had the university and as always, thanks for watching.